help us understand what machine learning
is because that seems to be the key
driver of so much of the excitement and
also the concern around artificial
intelligence how does machine learning
work so artificial intelligence and
machine learning is about 60 years old
and has not had a Great Danes pass until
recently and the reason is that today we
have reached a scale of computing and
data sets there was necessary to make
machine smart so here's how it works if
you program a computer today say your
phone then you hire software engineers
that write a very very long kitchen
recipe like if the water is too hot turn
on the temperature it was too cold to
another temperature the recipes are not
just ten lines long there are millions
of lines long and modern cell phone has
12 million lines of code a browser has 5
million lines of code and each bug in
this recipe can cause your computer
crash that's why a software engineer
makes so much money the new thing now is
that computers can find their own rules
so instead of an expert deciphering step
by step a rule for every contingency
what you do now is you give the computer
examples and have it influence own rules
a really good example is alphago
which recently was won by Google
normally in in game playing you would
really write on all the holes but in
alphago's case the system looked over
million games and was able to infer its
own rules and then beat the world's
residing a go champion that is exciting
because it relieves the software
engineer of the need of being super
smart and pushes the burden towards the
data as I said the inflection point
where this has become really possible
very embarrassing my fuse was about
machine learning it was completely
insignificant don't read it because was
20 years ago and back then the computers
were as
the cockroach brain now they are
powerful enough to really emulate kind
of specialized human thinking and then
the computers take advantage of the fact
that they can look at much more data
than people can so I'd say I forgot it
over more than a million games no human
expert can ever study a million games
Google has looked on over 100 billion
web pages no person can ever study on a
billion web pages so as a result the
computer can find rules that even keeper
can't find so it's kind instead of
looking ahead to if he does that I will
do that it's more saying here is what
looks like a winning pattern here is
what looks like it when he Adam I mean
think about how you raise children you
don't spend the first 18 years giving
the kids a rule for every contingency
and then set them free and then they
have this big program they stumble they
fall they get up they get slapped or
spanked and they have a positive
experience got a good grade in school
and they figured out on their own and
that's have these computers now which
makes computer programming so much
easier all of a sudden now we don't have
to think anymore just given lots of
there and so this has been key to the
spectacular improvement in power of auto
of self-driving cars I think you give me
an example can we can you explain what's
happening here this is a drive of a
self-driving car that we happen to have
a Udacity and recently made into a
spin-out quad voyage where we use the
sink or deep learning to train a car to
drive itself and this is driving from
Mountain View California to San
Francisco on El Camino Real
on a rainy day with bicyclists and
pedestrians and the Honda 33 traffic
lights and the knobby thing here is when
I I many many moons ago I started the
Google self-driving car team and back in
the day I had the world's best software
engineers to find the world's best rules
this has just trained we drive this vote
20 times we put all this data into the
computer brain and after a few hours of
processing it comes of it behavior that
often surpasses human agility so it's
become really easy to program it this is
a helps an autonomous about is 33 miles
an hour and a half so explain so on the
on this the big part of the program on
the Left you're seeing basically what
the computer seizes trucks and cars and
those crops overtaking it and so forth
on the right side you see the camera
image which is the main input here and
it's used to find lanes other cars
traffic lights the vehicle has a radar
to do distance estimation is very
commonly used in these kind of systems
on the left side you see a laser diagram
that you see obstacles like trees and so
on depicted by the laser but almost all
the interesting work is setting on the
camera image now we're really shifting
over from precision sensors like Vedas
and lasers into kind of very cheap
Kamala sends us a camera costs less than
$1 and that green dot and they on the
left thing what is that as a anything
meaning this is a look ahead point for
your adaptive cruise control so it helps
us understand how to regulate velocity
based on how far the cars in front of
you and so you've also got an example I
think of how the actual learning part
takes place maybe we can see that talk
about this this is an example where we
post the challenge to Udacity students
that take what we call a self-driving
car nanodegree and he gave him this data
said and said hey can you guys figure
out how to steer this car and if you
look at the images it's even for humans
quite impossible to to get the steering
right and we ran a competition and said
hey is a deep learning competition a a
competition and we gave the students 48
hours all right so if you're a software
house like Google or Facebook something
like this cost you ladies six months to
work so we figured 48 hours is great and
within 48 hours we got about a hundred
submissions from students and the top
four got it perfectly right it drives
better than I could drive on this
imagery using deep learning and again
it's the same methodology is this
magical thing when you give enough data
to a computer now and give enough time
to company the data it finds its own
rules and so that has led to development
of powerful applications in all sorts of
areas
you were talking me to me the other day
about cancer can I show this video yeah
absolutely this is core so this is a
kind of a insight into what's happening
in a completely different domain this is
augmenting or competing it's in the eye
of the beholder with people who are
being paid for and a thousand dollars a
year
dermatologist highly trained specialists
it takes more than a decade of training
to be a good dermatologist what you see
here is the machine learning version of
it it's called a neural network no
networks is the technical term for these
machine learning algorithms they've been
around since the 1980s this one has been
invented in 1988 by a Facebook fellow
called Jana Khan and it propagates data
stages through what you could think of
as the human brain it's not quite the
same thing
but it emulates the same thing it goes
stage after stage in the very first
stage it takes the visual input and
extract edges and rods and dots and the
next one become more complicated edges
and shapes like little half moons and
eventually it's able to build really
complicated concepts and ruing has been
able to show that it's able to find cat
faces and dog faces in vast amounts of
images what my student team assemble has
shown is that if you train it on a
hundred twenty nine thousand images of
skin conditions including melanoma and
carcinomas you can do as good a job as
the best human dermatologist and to
convince ourselves that is the case we
captured an independent dataset they
represented to our network and to 25
board-certified stanford level
dermatologists and compared those and in
most cases where either on par or above
the performance classification accuracy
of Unitologist new telling me an
anecdote I think about this this image
right here what happened here that is
this was last Thursday and it's that's a
moving part
piece so what we should be shown before
and we published in nature early this
year was this idea that we show
dermatologists images in our computer
program images and we counter often
they're right but all these images are
past images they'll been biopsied to
make sure we have the correct
classification this one wasn't though
this one was actually done at Stanford
there are no collaborators and the story
goes that our collaborator was a
world-famous dermatologist one of the
three best apparently looked at this
mole and said it's not skin cancer and
then he had a second moment where he
said let me just check with the app so
we took his iPhone and when our piece of
software
our pocket dermatologists for the speak
and and the iPhone said cancer
it said melanoma and then he was
confused and decide okay maybe I trust
the eye for a little bit more than
myself and he sent it out to the lab to
get it biopsied and it came out as an
aggressive melanoma so I think it might
be the first time that we actually found
in in the practices using deep learning
an actual person whose melanoma would
have gone unclassified had it not been
for deep learning I mean that's
incredible it feels like they'd been
instant demand for an app like this
right right now although you might freak
out a lot of people are you are you
thinking of doing this and making an app
that to allow self checking so my my
inbox is flooded about cancer apps with
heartbreaking stories of people and as
some people have had 10 15 20 ml and
almost removed and uh scared that this
one might be overlooked like this one
and also about I know flying car speaker
and fire because these days I guess my
take is we need more testing I want to
be very careful it's very easy to give a
flashy result and impress the Ted
audience it's much harder to put
something others ethical and if people
were to use the app and choose not to
consult the assistance of a doctor
because we get it wrong I would feel
really bad about it so we're currently
doing clinical tests and it is still
Curtis commands and our data holds up we
might be able at someone to take this
kind of technology and take it out of
the Stanford clinic um and bring it to
the entire world places where Stanford
doctors never have a set of foot and do
I hear this right that it seemed like
what you were saying because you're
working with this army of Udacity
students that in a way you're applying a
different form of machine learning that
might take place in in a company which
is you're combining machine learning
with a form of crowd wisdom are you
saying that sometimes you think that
could actually outperform what a company
can do even a vast company I believe
there's no instances that they blow my
mind and I still trying to understand
first what Chris is referring to is
these competitions every run we turn
them around in 48 hours and we've been
able to build a self-driving car that
can drive for Mountain View to
San Francisco on surface streets it's
not quite on par with Google after seven
years ago we work but it's getting there
and it took us only two engineers and
three months to do this and the reason
is we have an army of students who could
participate in competitions we are not
the only ones who use crowdsourcing uber
and ddu scores for driving
Airbnb uses crowdsourcing fool for
hotels there's no many examples where
people do but finding crowdsourcing or
protein folding of all things in
crowdsourcing but we've been able to
build this car in three months so I'm
actually rethinking how we organize
corporations we have a staff of nine
thousand people who are never hired
I never fire they show up to work and
other than no then they submit me maybe
nine thousand answers I'm not allowed to
use any of those I never pay only the
the winners so I'm actually very cheap
scored here which is not the best thing
to do but and they considered part of
Education too which is nice but but
these students have been able to produce
amazing deep learning results so yeah
these synthesis of great people and
great machine learning is amazing
I mean Garry Kasparov stood on the first
day that the winners of chess
surprisingly turned out to be too
amateur chess players with three
computers you know mediocre ish mediocre
- good computer programs could
outperform one grandmaster with one
great chess player like it was all part
of the process and yeah it only seems
like you're talking about a much more a
much richer version of that same idea
yeah I mean as you follow the fantastic
panels yesterday morning and through
sessions about AI robotic overlords and
the human response many many great
things were said but one of my concerns
is that the seminars confused was
actually with an AI with this kind of
Overlord threat
we are you I I there are lost
consciousness right the last thing I
want is to may I to behave consciousness
I don't want to come into my kitchen and
have the refrigerator just fallen in
love with the dishwasher and telling me
because it was nice enough my food is
now warm right I wouldn't I wouldn't buy
these products and I don't want them but
the truth is for me AI has always been
in augmentation
of people it's been the occupation of us
to make us stronger and I think Kasparov
was exactly correct it's been the
combination of human smarts and machine
smarts
that make us stronger the theme of of
machines making a stronger is as old as
machines are agricultural revolution
took place because he made steam engines
and farming equipment that couldn't
found by itself they never replaced as
made us stronger and I believe there's
no way for I they'll make us much much
much stronger as a human race so what
will come onto that a bit more but just
to continue with the sort of the scary
part of this for some people like what
what feels like it gets scary for people
is when you have computer that can one
rewrite its own code like so it can copy
it it can create multiple copies of
itself try a bunch of different code
versions possibly even at random and
then check them out and see if a goal is
achieved and improve so say the goal is
to do better on an intelligence test you
know a computer that was moderately good
at that you could try a million versions
of that you might find one that was
better and then you know repeat and so
it's I mean the concern is that you get
some sort of runaway effect where where
everything is fine on Thursday evening
you come back into the lab on Friday
morning and because of the speed of
computers and so forth just things have
gone crazy and suddenly I would okay you
know this is a possibility but it's a
very remote possibility so let me just
translate what I heard you say in the
alphago case we had exactly the same
computer would play the game against
itself and then learn the rules and what
machine learning is is a rewriting of
the rules
it's the rewriting of code but I think
there was absolutely no concern that
alphago would take over the world it
can't even play chess I don't know but
but but now these are all very sort of
single domain things but it's possible
to imagine we just saw a computer that
seemed capable nearly capable of passing
any university entrance test that can
kind of it can't read and understand in
the sense that we can but it can
certainly absorb all the text and maybe
see increased patterns of of meaning
isn't there isn't there
chance that as this broadens out that
there could be a different kind of
runaway effect so that's where I draw
the line honestly and the chance exists
I don't want to downplay it but I think
it's remote and it's not the thing
that's on my mind these days because I
think the big revolution is something
else
everything successful Nia in AI to the
present date has been extremely
specialized and it's been thriving on a
single idea which is massive amounts of
data the reason why alphago works so
well is because of massive number of
gold plays and alphago can't drive a car
or play a fly a plane the Google
self-driving car or the Udacity
self-driving car survives from massive
amounts of data and it can't do anything
else they can't even control a
motorcycle it's a very specific domain
specific function and the same is true
for cancer app there has been almost no
progress on this whole thing called
general AI or where we're good in AI and
say hey invent for me special relativity
or string theory it's totally in the
infancy the reason why I want to
emphasize is I see the concerns and I
wanna acknowledge them but if I were to
think about one thing I would ask myself
the question what if we can take
anything repetitive and make ourselves a
hundred times as efficient it so turns
out 300 years ago we all worked in
agriculture and didn't farming and did
repetitive things today 75% of us worked
in offices and do repetitive things
we've become spreadsheet monkeys and not
just low-end labor
we've become dermatologists doing
repetitive things Lauria student pair of
things I think we're at the brink of
being able to take in the I look over
our shoulders and they make us maybe 10
or 50 times as effective in this repair
of things that's what is my mind that
sounds super exciting that the process
of getting there seems a little
terrifying to some people because once a
computer can do this repetitive thing
much better you know than the
dermatologist or than the driver
especially is the thing that's talked
about so much now suddenly millions of
jobs go and you know the country's in
revolution before before we ever get to
the more glorious aspects yeah
and that's that's an issue and it's
really an issue and it was pointed out
yesterday morning by several your
speakers now prior to me showing up on
stage I confess them I'm a positive
optimistic person so let me give me your
optimistic pitch which is think of
herself back say 300 years ago Europe
just survived 140 years of continuous
war none of you could read a ride there
were no jobs that you hold today like
investment banker or software engineer
or TV anchor we would all be in the
fields and farming and now here comes a
long little Sebastian with a little
steam machine his profits say hey guys
look at this guy it's gonna make you
guys a hundred times as strong so you
can do something else and then back in
the day there was no real stage but
Chris my hanging up with the cows in the
stable and he says I'm really concerned
about it because I milk my cow every day
and whatever machine does this for me
the reason why I mentioned this is we
always good in like acknowledging past
progress and benefit if it we are like
our iPhones or planes or electricity
our medical supply we all love to live
to 80 which was impossible too many
years ago but we are kind of don't apply
the same rules to the future so if I
look at my own job as a CEO I would say
90% my work is repetitive I don't enjoy
it I spend about four hours email per
day on stupid repetitive email and I'm
burning to have something that helps me
get rid of this why because I believe
all of us are insanely creative I think
the tech community more than anybody
else but even blue-collar workers I
think and go to your hotel mate and have
a drink with him or her and an hour
later you find a creative idea but this
van powers is to turn his creativity
into action like what if you could build
Google in a day what if you could sit
over at beer and invent the next
snapchat whatever it is and tomorrow
morning it's up and running and that is
not science fiction
what's going to happen is we are ready
in historic history we've unleashed his
amazing creativity by these slaving us
from farming in the last and and later
of course from
factory work and have invented so many
things it's it's going to be even better
in my opinion and this couldn't be great
side-effects one of the side effects
will be that things like food and
medical supply and education and shelter
and transportation will all become much
more affordable to all of us not just
average people hmm
so when Martin forward argued you know
that this time it's different because
the intelligence that we've used in the
past to find new ways to be will be
matched at the same pace by by kind of
computers taking over those those things
what I hear you saying is that not
completely because because of you know
human creativity do you think that
that's fundamentally different from the
kind of creativity that that computers
can do so there's my there's my firm
belief as an AI person that I haven't
seen any real progress on creativity and
out-of-the-box thinking what I really
see right now and it's really important
for people to realize because the word
artificial intelligence is so
threatening and then we have Steve
Spielberg tossing a movie in where all
of a sudden the cookies are overlords
but it's really a technology it's a
technology that helps us do repetitive
things and the progress has been
entirely on the repetitive end it's in
legal document discovery it's been
contract drafting it's been screening I
know
x-rays of your chest and these things
are so specialized I don't see the big
threat of humanity in fact vs people I
mean let's face it we become superhuman
we've made us superhuman we can swim
across the Atlantic in 11 hours we can
take a device of our pocket and shout
all the way to Australia and in real
time have the person shouting back to us
that's physically not possible we
breaking the rules of physics if this
when this is said and done you're going
to remember everything we ever said and
seen you're gonna member every person
which is good for me as my early stages
of Alzheimer so I would yeah leave in
heaven we would probably have enough a
queue of a thousand two or more you'll
be able to there will be known as
spelling classes for kids because
there's no spelling issue anymore
there's no math issue anymore
and I think what really will happen is
we can be super creative and we are we
are creative it's our secret weapon so
so the jobs that are getting lost in a
way even though it's gonna be painful
humans are capable of more than those
jobs this is the work the dream the
dream is that humans can rise to just a
new level of empowerment and in
discovery that's the dream and think
about this if you if you look at the
history of humanity that might be what
has 60 hundred thousand years old give
and take almost everything that you
cherish in terms of invention of
technology of things we built has been
invented last 150 years we toss in the
book in the wila slivered order or the X
but your phone sneakers these fierce
modern manufacturing penicillin the
things we cherish now that to me means
the next hundred fifty years we'll find
more things in fact the pace of
invention has gone up not gone down in
my opinion I believe only 1% of
interesting things have been invented
yet right we haven't cured cancer
we don't have flying cars yet hopefully
I'll changes used to be an example
laughed about it's funny isn't it
well secretly on flying cars we don't
live twice as long yet okay we don't
have this magic implant in you our brain
so they give us the information you want
and you might be appalled by it but I
promise you once you have it you'll love
it
I hope you know it's bit scary I know
there's so many things we haven't
invented yet that I think we invent we
have no gravity shields
if you can't beam assess from a location
another that sounds ridiculous but about
two hundred years ago experts were of
the opinion flight wouldn't exist even
hundred twenty years ago and if you move
faster than you could value would
instantly die right so who says if
you're correct today that you can't beam
a person from here to Mars
Sebastian thank you so much to your
incredibly inspiring vision and your
brilliance Thank You Sebastian birth
put that down